- - Hélène Buzzetti, Michel C.
AuAuger, Michel David, bonsoir.
UnUn petit mot sur Jean-Yves
DuDuclos, son annonce, je le
didisais, on solidifie les
dédéfenses sans tout chambouler.
OnOn dit, ce qui rend, vous devz
vovous faire tester.
- - Mais quand apprendrons-nous
nonos leçons?
JeJe ne comprends pas pourquoi n
ararrive avec des mesures plus
mumusclées qui diraient: ce qui
rerend au Canada, vaccinés ou ps
vavaccinés, doivent absolument e
memettre en quarantaine et subir
unun test à quelque part entre e
ququatrième et le huitième jour
apaprès son arrivée.
OnOn le sait, et espère l'entré,
adadmettons que la personne viee
dadans notre pays, un test fait
dadans les 24 heures ne sera pas
susuffisamment fiable, ce pourrt
êêtre un faux négatif.
IlIl faut attendre la période c,
c'c'est du quatrième au huitième
jojour.
AlAlors je ne comprends pas
popourquoi on n'y va pas par une
apapproche par étapes.
CÇa me semble une bonne
rerecette...
- - Vous trouvez cela trop doux?
OKOK, Michel C. Auger?
- - On est voisin avec les État-
UnUnis.
MaMais en même temps, quand on
vovoit ce qu'il se passe aux
EÉtats-Unis, c'est un des
enendroits, le sud des États-Uns
enen particulier, c'est un des
enendroits les plus touchés para
COCOVID en général.
OnOn verra ce qu'il arrive avece
nonouveau variant, mais c'est
ququand même un drôle de message
enenvoyé.
JeJe ne suis pas sûr que c'est e
bobon message envoyé.
- - Michel David?
- - On avait reproché beaucoup u
gogouvernement fédéral en févrir
dede ne pas avoir réagi assez
vivite.
IlIl réagit, mais avec des demi-
memesures.
EÉvidemment, c'est incomplet.
C'C'est mieux que rien, mais je
pepense... je ne vois pas commet
lala situation ne pourrait pas
dédégénérer.
LeLes mesures sont annoncées
auaujourd'hui, sont à mon sens n
prpréliminaire, qui en annonce s
plplus difficiles dans les
prprochains jours, dans les
prprochaines semaines.
- - Hélène, je ne dis pas si vos
avaviez participé à toutes les.
1313.
OnOn est plus là-dedans.
EsEst-ce que ça ne vous pouvait
papas fléchir dans votre analys?
- - On n'en a déjà parlé avec vs
etet moi.
OnOn ne peut pas fermer les
frfrontières.
OnOn ne peut pas empêcher aux
CaCanadiens de rentrer dans leur
prpropre pays.
CÇa ne veut pas dire qu'on ne
dedevrait pas se mettre en
ququarantaine.
MoMonsieur David parlé, peut-ête
lele premier pas, je suis d'accd
avavec lui, mais ça fait qu'on t
totoujours un peu derrière.
OnOn va toujours réagir qu'on va
avavoir une augmentation des
cocorps.
SeSe placer en quarantaine entre
reretour de voyage, ce n'est pas
bebeaucoup te demander de
papatienter sous huitième jour.
CeCe n'est pas beaucoup demandé,
mamais ça éviterait des
cocontaminations par des persons
ététant vacciné n'auront pas
bebeaucoup de symptômes, ne sert
papas qu'ils sont porteurs de ce
vavariant, ils vont pouvoir le
didisséminer partout.
EtEt pour ce qui est des États-
UnUnis, ce qu'on nous dit en
cocoulisses, c'est qu'il y aurat
trtrop de monde, ça représentert
bebeaucoup trop de monde, on
n'n'aurait pas une quantité assz
dede tests.
- - OK, très bien, c'est réglé,
mamais c'est pas réglé pour cel.
JeJe vous ai entendu sur cela.
NoNoël.
LeLes jambes des grandes famills
auau Québec encore, mais quelqus
heheures avant son ministre mais
ilil n'oubliait pas, c'est 10
pepersonnes maximum.
AlAlors on va entendre ce que ça
crcréé à Québec aujourd'hui.
- - Si on veut que les règles
sosoient respectées, on peut pas
jujuste lancer dans l'air
dedes souhaits comme ça. C'est a
ququi crée de la confusion.
GAGABRIEL NADEAU DUBOIS
- - Quand François Legault
fafait ça, il prend les devants
susur la science. En pandémie,
lala politique devrait se ranger
dederrière la science.
FRFRANÇOIS LEGAULT,
prpremier ministre du Québec
- - On m'a demandé : "Vous,
esest-ce que vous pensez
ququ'il faudrait assouplir
lele nombre de personnes
dadans les maisons?" J'ai dit
quque, moi, j'étais ouvert à ça,
mamais que je me fierais
àà Santé publique.
SiSi on peut plus dire ce qu'on
pepense, on a un problème.
- - Ça vous a fait sourire Michl
DaDavid.
BiBien sûr qu'il peut dire ce
ququ'il pense, mais quand le
prpremier ministre dit à haute
vovoix ce qu'il pense, ça a plus
dede portique quand vous et moin
paparle.
- - Il peut dire ce qu'il pense,
mamais ce n'est pas toujours bon
ququand on dit ce qu'on pense.
EtEt c'est un bon exemple
auaujourd'hui.
JeJe me mets dans l'du Dr Arrud:
ououi, mon patron veut absolumet
ququ'on fasse des parties à Noë.
SiSi je dis, c'est lui qui va
peperdre la face.
SiSi par exemple il juge que ces
popossibles sans grand risque et
ququ'il autorise, on va tous se
dedemander: est-ce qu'il pense
vrvraiment que il n'y a pas de
ririsque ou il ne veut pas mette
soson patron dans l'embarras?
EtEt si on se dit ce cas sert ds
inintérêts politiques, ça crée n
dodoute.
- - Même si tout sera fait avec
totous les bons éléments...
- - Même si ces faits de bonne i
etet sincèrement, doit
s's'installait.
- - Michel C. Auger.
- - Ils annoncent des choses : n
lele fait ou on le fait pas.
SiSi c'est Monsieur Arruda qui t
dadans une situation impossibleà
cacause de cela.
DeDes fois, Monsieur Legault a s
fofois le réflexe de vouloir ête
lele bon gars dans l'affaire.
MaMais le premier ministre ne pt
papas être un bon gars tout le
tetemps.
IlIl y a des fois où il va poser
dede la confusion ou créer des
coconflits potentiels.
- - Hélène.
- - Je suis d'accord avec tout e
quque mes collègues ont dit.
IlIl a un peu télégraphié ses
ininterventions.
CeCeci dit, j'ai quand même
coconfiance que Dr Arruda est
asassez solide pour prendre ses
dédécisions.
EtEt même s'il devait s'en tenià
lala règle actuelle, je ne suis
papas certain que ça ferait pasr
MoMonsieur Legault si fou que
cecela, compte tenu de tous les
rerevirements qu'on a eu l'année
papassée.
- - Est-ce que les gens vont
susuivre le 10, mais à un moment
dodonné, voilà.
GeGerber ne lâche pas le morcea.
LeLes documents que la coronaira
dedemandés, ce ne sont pas les
bobons, et elle, on sait vite ce
ququ'elle pense.
CÇa s'est ramassé à la période e
ququestions.
EÉcouter quelques échanges.
OnOn a appris qu'il y avait 11 0
fifiches qui vont finalement
enenvoyer.
MAMARC TANGUAY, porte-parole,
PLPLQ, accès à l'information
- - Les rapports d'inspection
reremplies manuellement sont où?
OnOn peut-tu en avoir copie?
UnUne fois que j'ai dit ça,
çaça peux pas être plus clair
quque ça.
CHCHRISTIAN DUBÉ, ministre
dede la Santé, Québec
- - Les rapports dont le député
paparle sont sur le site Web
dedepuis longtemps, Monsieur...
PaParce que c'est de l'informatn
ququi a été transparente.
- - C'est à ça que ça sert
unune commission d'enquête.
CoContraindre la personne
àà répondre. On commence
àà avoir des nouvelles.
LaLa Commissaire à la santé
etet au bien-être a un mandat
dede s'occuper de la performance
dudu système, mais elle trouvera
papas les responsables.
LeLes familles éplorées veulent
sasavoir qui est responsable.
- - Monsieur, on va...
onon va prendre ça calmement, l.
TrTrès calmement.
PuPuis je demanderais aux députs
dede bien écouter ce que j'ai dt
dadans les deux premières partis
dede la réponse.
- - M. Dubé 10 : ça existe les
dodocuments, ils sont disponibl.
BoBon.
AuAu-delà de ce que...
OnOn voit que l'opposition a
chchangé là-dessus et qu'il ne a
sesera pas le morceau.
MiMichel C. Auger.
OnOn ne laissera pas passer chae
dédétail ou ce n'est pas que la.
- - Ils ne le seront rien passé
tatant qu'ils n'auront pas une
cocommission normal, comme on au
dadans d'autres domaines.
CÇa c'est certain.
IlIl y a quand même apparence, u
momoins, de vouloir cacher des
chchoses.
EtEt c'est ce que le gouvernemet
nene peut pas se permettre à ce
momoment-ci.
D'D'abord, parce que mentir un
cocoroner c'est aussi graves que
dede mentir à une commission
d'd'enquête publique.
JeJe ne dis pas qu'ils ont ment,
mamais ça ne sent pas bon.
OnOn leur a donné des résumés,
paparce qu'on voulait accélérera
ttâche...
- - Ils n'ont pas nécessairement
mementi, mais ça soulève un dou.
IlIl y a un manque de clarté,
d'd'honnêteté...
dede netteté...
- - au début il n'existait pas s
dodocuments.
MaMaintenant on est rendu à 11
00000.
AlAlors il y a clairement une
évévolution.
CeCe n'est pas des détails
nénécessairement.
QuQuand on dit qu'on fait un
rérésumé, par définition, résumé
çaça veut dire certaines choses.
IlIl note qu'il y a des absence,
dedes manques.
AlAlors si on veut vraiment savr
cece que le gouvernement a faitu
nene pas fait, il faut la
chchronologie des rapports.
IlIl faut qu'on sache à quelle
dadate...
- - on est dans une forêt de
dédétails.
- - Exactement, c'est de cette
foforêt qu'apparaît ce portrait.
- - J'hésite entre être
chcharitable, à c'est une erreur
dadans l'entrée de données, pare
ququ'il y a tellement des
inincongruités... et dans les
rérésumé on donne e des réponseà
cece... mon Dieu, est-ce que il
pepensait que la coroner
mamais je suis assez d'accord ac
MiMichel David.
EnEn bout de piste, ces détails
sosont beaucoup moins
imimportants...
QuQuand on les a reçus, a-t-on
agagi?
- - Très bien.
LeLes éducatrices ont réussi, ot
gagagné leur pari.
ElElles vont passer de 19 à 21 $
etet de 25 et 18 à 30 $ de leur.
C'C'est une augmentation de...
popourtant, ce qui nous écoute,
dedemain il y a une grève pour s
40400 CPE qui sont syndiqués avc
l'l'CSN.
PaParce que les autres employés
auautour, le gouvernement ne vet
papas les augmenter autant.
JeJe repose la question que j'ai
poposé l'autre semaine.
QuQui a le gros bout du bâton :
leles syndicats ou le
gogouvernement, dans ce dossier
lala?
LeLes parents se retrouvent clos
dadans ce dossier la.
- - Je pense que c'est dangereux
popour les parents.
OnOn ne beaucoup de sympathie pr
eueux, mais je pense que les
paparents...
EtEt si vous avez un enfant en
gagarderie pendant la pandémie,
leles parents de jeunes enfants
sosont exténués, sont à bout, et
dedevra poindre une grève à
l'l'horizon, je pense qu'ils ne
seseront pas...
CÇa dépend desquels, mais,
évévidemment, je pense qu'ils vt
avavoir de la difficulté à rallr
leleur clientèle, parce qu'ils
sosont exténués et on comprend
popourquoi.
CeCe - c'est une arme à utiliser
avavec prudence.
- - Mais en même temps, la
sisituation dans les CPA est qud
mmême difficile.
MMême si les éducatrices ont eu
unune augmentation... un moment
dodonné, la cuisinière qui ne pt
s's'en augmentation voilà voir à
chchaque jour.
C'C'est ça aussi qui motive les
gegens des CPE, ils ne vont pas
nonous diviser pour régner.
- - De rester solidaire.
- - Je pense que oui.
EtEt c'est un peu inévitable qul
lele fasse.
- - Michel David.
- - Pour répondre à votre premie
ququestion : qui a le gros boutu
bbâton?
SiSi ça... mais à quoi qu'on
asassiste, l'ultime bataille des
sysyndicats contre les tests
d'd'hérésie qu'a proférée le
gogouvernement en décidant que e
n'n'est pas vrai que tout le moe
vava avoir les mêmes
auaugmentations.
EtEt ça, ça passe mal.
OnOn le voit là. Ce n'est pas tt
lele monde qui gagne le même
sasalaire.
AlAlors c'est certain que les
cocorps va encore augmenter icie
gogouvernement accordent 20 % ax
édéducatrices et seulement neuvs
àà d'autres catégories.
AlAlors, c'est doublement chacun
popour un syndicat.
PoPour ce qui est des parents, s
sosont évidemment pris en otage,
paparce qu'ils doivent trouver
auautre chose, mais il y a une
sosolidarité un peu forcée.
C'C'est-à-dire que les parents
n'n'ont pas bien le choix de ête
sosolidaires aux éducatrices.
IlIls ne peuvent pas se retournr
cocontre elle.
- - Très bien, merci à vous tro.
OnOn va suivre l'évolution de
MoMonsieur Duclos, mais je sais
quque vous avez trouvé cela
ininsuffisant.
OnOn va suivre ce déba